اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام نتابع واياكم
هذه التغطيه المتواصله من العربيه للكارثه
التي حلت بتركيا وسوريا على اثر الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب البلدين في اخر تحديثات
لارقام الضحايا عدد القتلى وصل في تركيا
الى
2316 قتيلا وفي سوريا وصل الرقم الى
1371 قتيلا بينما تتواصل عمليات رفع
الانقاض في كلا البلدين الامم المتحده
كانت حذرت من ان اعداد الضحايا مرشحه
للارتفاع بقوه بسبب وجود الاف المباني
المنهاره كليا او جزئيا بينما تتواصل جهود
الاغاثه الدوليه واحدثها اعلان العراق عن
فتح جسر جوي الى تركيا وسوريا
[موسيقى]
احنا
نايمين
على مين هذا هون
[موسيقى]
والله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صور ماساويه الاكيد ان هول الكارثه لم
يتكشف بعد بكل ارقامه وحقائق وتفاصيله
نتابع في تغطيتنا افادت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه بان ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان قدمت تعازي هاتفيا للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في ضحايا الزلزال
واكد الامير محمد بن سلمان وقوف السعوديه
ومساندتها لتركيا لتجاوز هذه الكارثه
الطبيعيه بدوره اعرب اردوغان عن تقديره
لوقوف السعوديه الى جانب تركيا في هذا
الظرف الصعب
اعلنت السلطات الرومانيه ارساله وحدات
انقاذ الى تركيا للمساعده في عمليات
الاغاثه جراء تداعيات الزلزال وتتضمن
الفرق تلك عشرات من المتخصصين بالانقاذ
اضافه الى عدد من الكلاب المدربه على
البحث تحت الانقط
وقد اكد بيان للجيش الاسرائيلي ان بعثه
مشتركه للدفاع والخارجيه تحمل اسم اغصان
الزيتون ستتوجه الى المنطقه التي وقع فيها
الزلزال المدمر في تركيا لتقديم المساعده
البعثه التي تتراسها قياده الجبهه
الداخليه ستغادر على متن طائرات تابعه
لسلاح الجو من قاعده نيفا طيما وستباشر
بمجرد وصولها في مهمه الانقاذ والاغاثه
وقال رئيس برنامج الغذاء العالميه ان فرق
الطوارئ التابعه للبرنامج تستعد لتقديم
المساعده اذا اقتضت الضروره بعد الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا وقدم عبر حسابه على
موقع تويتر تعازيه لعائله ضحايا الزلزال
ونتابع واياكم مع
الصحفيين والمراسلين المنتشرين في المناطق
المتضرره من هذا الزلزال نبدا من اسطنبول
مع الكاتب الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو اهلا
بك استاذ فراس مره جديده اخر واحدث
المعلومات التي تحصلت عليها او اطلعت
عليها من السلطات التركيه او الاعلام
التركي حول
عمليات الانقاذ
يعني ممكن اخر خبر الذي نشر عبر الاعلام
تقريبا منذ ممكن ان نقول
خمسه عشر دقيقه عن هزه ارضيه بمقدار 5.3
في ايضا منطقه مرعش هي لم يذكر زكاه
ارتداديه ام ام هزه حقيقيه في في هذا
السياق ربما هذا احدث خبر الان وصلاه قبل
عشره دقيقه عن هزه ارضيه جديده اذا قد
تكون هزارتداديه للزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
نفس المنطقه التي نتحدث عنها وهي مرعش
والتوقعات ايضا باستمرار هذه الهزات وفقا
لمن لخبراء الزلازل الذين يتحدثون الى
وسائل الاعلام التركيه
نعم هذا صحيح يعني الهزه القويه التي حصلت
ربما في الساعه الرابعه يعني الاخبار تقول
حتى في المناطق الشماليه او سامسونج وتلك
المناطق البعيده
شعروا بها بشكل واضح هذه حتى الان اظن 5.3
ربما فقط في المنطقه القريبه من مرعش
والمناطق مثل
غازي عنتاب وقريبه من ديار بكر كيرلس تلك
المناطق ايضا تم الشعور بها ايضا هناك بعض
الاخبار عن البنك المركزي التركي قبل ربما
نصف ساعه او ساعه تقريبا صدر خبر منه بانه
لجميع الشركات التي في الولايات العشره
المتضرره تم تاجيل او ايقاف القروض
وما شابه ذلك الى سته شهور قادمه ولاحقه
والكريدي كارد وما شابه ذلك الى بعض سته
اشهر وحتى دون الفائده التي كانت مذكوره
وهذه يعني ايضا من البنك المركزي التركي
الاعداد القتلى حتى الان كما ذكرتم قبل
قليل لم يتغير حتى الان 2316 ايضا النداء
الذي قبل تقريبا اقل من ساعه كان صدر ايضا
من الهلال الاحمر وبعض الجهات الطبيه
التخوف من ما يسمى
نقص في حراره الجسم نتيجه البروده الشديده
في تلك المناطق هيبوتيرم
وهذا يتطلب ايضا المجهودات الطبيه تطالب
بها حقيقه كثير من الجهات الطبيه هذه ابرز
الصعوبات اذا التي تواجه عمليات الانقاذ
الان ان نتحدث عن البرد القارس كصعوبه او
يعني كصعوبه اقصى
وايضا عن حلول الليل والظلام ايضا اللي
يعرقل عمليات الاغاثه اضافه الى ما ابرز
هذه الصعوبات التي يتحدث عنها الاعلام
التركي
نعم عندما بدانا في مساله نقص حراره الجسم
هذا يعطينا على ان ليس الجميع ربما لديه
البطانيات الكافيه ليس الجميع لديهم ما
يدفئ نفسه وليس الجميع ربما في ماوى كافي
رغم كل فتح جميع المراكز الدينيه
والرياضيه والمدارس وكلها ربما لم تستوعب
كل هذا والذين ايضا يخشون من الجلوس بسبب
الهزات الاعتداديه او ربما زلزال اخر اذا
هذا الخبر دلالات على ادناه ليس الجميع
بخير حتى الان اظن ايضا نقطه اخرى في في
مساله القطاع التيار الكهربائي في بعض
المناطق الطرقات المقطوعه هذه تسبب ايضا
تاخر في يعني حتى لو وصلت لمساعدات تاخر
في وصول المساعدات والسند الى تلك المناطق
في المساعدات التي توليها حتى الان لم
تعني الحكومه عن توزع الرجال انقاذ التي
جاءت لمساعده
عن وصول اكثر من 420 شخصا للقازمه معداتهم
ودوال اخرى ايضا لكن الى اين وكيف التوزيع
حقيقه حتى الان لم يتم نشر اي خارطه لهذا
العمل انا اظن الوضع ربما في الليل درجات
حراره الطقس بشكل كبير
الاجواء في بعض المناطق ربما توقفه هطول
الامطار وهذا ربما شيء جيد الى ان تحين
يعني الساعات القادمه لاستخراج ما يمكن
استخراجه وايقاف ويمكن انقاذه من الارقاد
وطبعا حتى الان الجيش لم يغير اي من
تصريحاته التي صرح قبل قليل عن وجود
البارجه في البحر المتوسط في منطقه هاتاي
لتصبح كمشفى عائم وايضا تعود اليك الاهالي
هناك وايضا اسمح لي اعود اليك بعد قليل ان
اتابع معك بعد قليل الصحفي السوري ابراهيم
الادلبي ينضم الى الان من ادلب ويطلعنا
على اخر يعني ما يحصل على الارض
كيف يمكن ان تروي لنا الواقع في هذه
اللحظات ابراهيم
مساء النور
الجميع وصل عدد الضحايا حتى هذه اللحظايه
مقارب 733 شخص كانوا قد لقوا حذفهم في
شمال غرب سوريا ادلب وريف حلب فرق الانقاذ
لا تزال تعمل في المناطق الاكثر تضررا
بدايه من الاتارب الوصول الى جنديرس ايضا
في سرمده وحارم والقرى
الواقعه ما بين مدينه سرمدا وحارب هذه
المناطق التي ذكرتها هي الاكثر تضررا حتى
هذه اللحظه واعداد الوفيات المرتفعه في
هذه المناطق اضافه الى ان الفرق فرق
الدفاع المدني والمتطوعين المدنيين
والمنظمات الانسانيه العامله داخل العرب
السوريه اللازمه لا تزال تعمل الى هذه
الساعات بضمن ظروف جويه قاسيه جدا اضافه
الى
الادوات البسيطه التي يملكها المتطوعون من
اجل ازاله الارقام واستخراج المصابين من
تحت الارض يتم نقلهم الى النقاط الطبيه او
حتى الى المستشفيات وذلك بحسب حاله
الاستخراج بالحديث عن المستشفيات طاهر لو
سمحتي الوضع ماساوي جدا في المستشفيات
بدايه من مشفى العسكري في مدينه عفرين هذا
المشفى الذي عمل فوق قدرته الاستيعابيه
بالنسبه للكادر الطبي وعلى المستوى
المساحه تم مناشده بعض المصابين بعد
التلقيم الطبابه داخل المشفى بالخروج الى
منطقه خارج المشهد من اجل ايجاد مساحه او
مكان اخر لمصاب اخر لتلقي العلاج بعض
المصابين والعلاج على ابواب المشافي
من المعنيين يعني بالنسبه لادخال
المساعدات بالنسبه الى المعابر بالنسبه
الى المناطق التي تخضع لسيطره المعارضه
كلها كيف يمكن ان تتلقى مثل هذه المساعدات
عمليات الانقاذ من الخارج
من
ظمات توزيع العديد من المؤن هي لا تكفي
لاعداد كبيره جدا ولكن بقدر المستطاع
الجمعيه من اجل تقاسم كل شيء بالنسبه
للمساعدات الخارجيه حتى الان لم يتم رصد
او دخول اي شيء لا من من الحدود السوريات
تركيا ولا من مناطق والمعابر التي كانت
ترعرعها ما بين مناطق المعارضه ومناطق
النظام هناك طبعا محاولات جاهزه على
المستوى المدني الداخلي من اجل المساهمه
والمساعده بانتشال اجزز او حتى اخراج ناس
ما زالوا على قيد الحياه من تحت الانقاذ
خليك معنا ابراهيم فراس باعتقادك تركيا في
وسط كل يعني هذه المعمعه التي تعيشها
ستكون قادره على امداد يد العون الى
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه في
سوريا والتي يعني كانت عاده ما تمرر لها
المساعدات
يعني انا اظن خلال 24 او 48 ساعه هناك
يعني لنقل الضياع او عدم القدره ايضا
للوصول لتلك المناطق ربما الكوادر التي
موجوده في داخل تركيا التي تستطيع ان
تساعد نفسها او تكفي نفسها لذلك طلبت
المساعده من خارج ذلك انا حتى الان ما
سمعت عن ارسال الله اعلم يعني هل تم او لا
لكن ما سمعت حتى الان عن ارسال
واقيمت طوارئ التركيه الى تلك المناطق رغم
التواصل القديم يعني موجود في في تلك
المناطق بينها وبين تركيا لكن الان ما
سمعت لذلك يعني انا اظن انها هذه النقطه
ايضا نقطه
الحقيقه سيئه لا يوجد تواصل لا اعلم عندما
تصل المساعدات بشكل اقوى واكثر الى تركيا
هل سيتم ممكن
التخصيص بعض هذه
الفرق بالتوجه الى هناك لكن حتى الان يعني
ما سمعنا شيئا حقيقه عن اصول فرق انقاذ
تركيا الى تلك المناطق لا من الجانب
التركي ولا اظن من الجانب على امل ان
يتفوق العمل الانساني على اي عوامل اخرى
كانت سياسيه او امنيه او غيرها تبقى معنا
فراس اعود اليك ابراهيم
هناك عائلات باكملها قبض خاصه في تلك
المناطق التي ذكرتها قبل قليل بسرمدا
بالمناطق اللي تحدثنا عنها
كيف هو يعني وضع الناس
والعدد يبدو انه وفق الخبراء مرشح
للارتفاع
اضعاف مضاعفه هل هذا هو الواقع عندكم نعم
الواقع الاعداد مرشحه للزياده بشكل مرعب
جدا لانه نتحدث عن تجمعات سكنيه قرى احياء
سقط المنازل على راس قاطنيها لان ساعه
الاستهداف او سعد الزلزال الاول الذي ضرب
المنطقه الشماليه ومناطق الحساب جنوب
تركيا فكانت في تمام الساعه الرابعه و 12
دقيقه اي الجميع كانوا نائمين ضمن هذه
المجمعات اتحدث عن ابنيه مهترئه مستطيعه
جراء عمليه الحرج الراء الحرب والقصف
المتواصل الذي كان استهدف بشكل مباشر
واستهدف مناطق اخرى
في شمال غرب سوريا لذلك الابنيه القديمه
ساهمت ايضا تهدمت على راس قطين لذلك
الاعداد مرشحه لزياده
اللي سمعت عنها القصص الانسانيه المؤلمه
اللي سمعت عنها او عاينتها
حقيقه
الفيديوهات التي وصلت والمناشدات كان
اصعبها هو عندما تحدثت الطفله عن انها
تريد الحديث مع والدها وبدا عناصر الدفاع
المدني بامتصاص حاله الرعب من خلال ان
والدك سياتي ومن خلال لا تخافي نحن سنقوم
باخراجك كل شيء تمام يعني عمليات تهدئه
المدنيين العالقين تحت بان هناك امل
باستخراجهم يبقوا على قيد الحياه ويشاهدوا
الحياه من جديد او يطمحون الى مستقبل افضل
من الواقع الحالي ايضا القصص الاخرى هي
القصه المستمره حاليا المدنيون اليوم او
الان تحديدا ينامون بالعراء مع اعتقادهم
لمؤولات الدفع وذلك بسبب الخوف من البقاء
ضمن الاحياء السكنيه بعد مناشدات من
الجهات المختصه والدفاع المدني بخروج
هؤلاء الى العراء والى الاراضي الزراعيه
للاحتماء ايضا
حتى الان يفترسون الارض في الخارج
احتماء من اي ارتداديه او زل اخر
تماما لان الهزاز الارتزاديه وايضا
الزلزال الثاني الذي ضرب المنطقه في قريب
الساعه ما بين اسبانيا ايضا ادى الى خلق
اعلى من الرعب ورد فعل بعدم الاقتراب من
هذه المباني المهتريه خشيه على حياتهم
اليوم يقاومون زلزال ولكن ايضا يقاومون
بنفس الوقت على البرد
والطق الجوي المنطقه ابقى معنا هل هذا هو
الواقع ايضا في في المناطق المتضرره من
تركيا
نعم يعني في في تركيا
ربما المساحات اوسع حتى يعني اذا قارنا من
ديار بكر باتجاه
الاسكندرون كثير من الناس حقيقه في الخارج
حتى هنا في اسطنبول لان الناس تتكلم عن
لانها ربما لن تنام
متخوفه من اي هزه قد تاتي الى اسطنبول
اليوم بشكل عام اسطنبول كانت غير مزدحمه
لا يوجد فيها ازدحام وهذا ليس من عادتها
ابدا انه الناس خايفين انت كيف عشت
التجربه شخصيا صحيح
الحقيقه يعني منذ الصباح الباكر عندي كثير
من الاصدقاء والاقارب في منطقه عنتاب
تحديدا من الصباح الباكر يعني بعضهم
تواصلنا معهم وبعضهم لكن في النهايه الكل
الحمد لله بخير وسلام ولكن الكل يشكر من
نفس الخوف الهلعوه لا يريد العوده الى
البيت لا يريد لكن بعض اصدقائنا هنا للاسف
فقدوا احبائهم في في تلك المناطق وسافروا
ولكن بسبب الطرقات والعزل الحقيقه يعني لا
يستطيعون ان يصلوا الى تلك المناطق
ولذويهم وفي نفس الوقت يعني هم في حاله
انسانيه سيئه جدا اليوم يعني لا نعلم هل
لا اظن احدا سينام يعني حتى ربما انا ربما
لن انام لان ننتظر مع الاولاد مع الجميع
لنعلم هل سيحصل شيء ارتدادات متابعه
الاخبار الى الخروج للشارع مثلا عندما
حصلت
عندما حصلت زلزال يعني بشكل شخصي مع
عائلتك او كان الموضوع اخف باسطنبول
في اسطنبول لا لم يكن اي حصول لكن انت
ذكرتني عندما حصل في عام 2019 حصلت هزه
ارضيه كبيره في في اسطنبول وصلت الى 6
درجات وقتها في النهار اذكر يعني خرجنا
فورا من البناء باتجاه
[موسيقى]
في كل حي يوجد ما يسمى نقطه التجمع في حال
وجود زلازل او ما شابه ذلك يعني شيء مخيف
حقيقه ان تحمل الصغير
وتركض وفي ولا تعلم ماذا سيحصل ستفتح عليه
الامور يعني حقيقه عموما حتى المتعودين
على الهزات والزلازل في في المنطقه
المتضرره يعني عم بيقولوا انه يعني لا شيء
يشبه هذا الزلزال تحديدا لانه هو خط صدع
يعني زلزالي معروف في تلك المنطقه التي
حصل فيها زلزال تبقى معنا ابراهيم كيف عشت
تجربه الزلزال
ابراهيم الادلبي تسمعني
ابراهيم تسمعني
طيب ريثما يعود الينا ابراهيم الادلبي
الصحفي السوري من ادلب لنتعرف على المزيد
مما يحصل هناك
نتابع في تغطياتنا وتبقيان معنا لو سمحتم
الادلبي تتعرض تركيا باستمرار لزلازل
وهزات ارضيه وحصدت ارواح الاف الضحايا
ودمرت المباني والبنى التحتيه نتعرف
منذ عام 1500 شهيد التركي نحو 23 زلزالا
مدمرا تجاوزت قوتها سبع درجات وفق تقديرات
علماء الجيولوجيا والمؤرخين زلزال ارزنجان
1939 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله تسعه تسبب
بمسرع 33 الف شخص واصابه نحو 100 الف
زلزال لاديك
1943 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله سته دمر
75% من ابنيه المنطقه واودى بحياه 2300
شخص
زلزال تشالديران بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله خمسه تسبب بمسرع ثلاثه الاف
وثمانمائه واربعين شخصا
زلزال بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله اثنين
تسبب بمسرع
894 شخصا
زلزالو فان 2011 بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله اثنين ادى الى وفاه اكثر من 70 شخصا
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر حاره كابلي بحارب حاره كامله
بحارب
بدنا نحكم العالم
تعاونها اتفرجهم يا يا
العالم كلها جايه ربحوا ما تعاونها
كل واحد قاعد
اتفرجوا اتفرجوا يساعدنا
هل عنده نخوه ونتابع من زياره مدينه
مالطيه بشرق تركيا وهي احدى المدن التي
تضررت بشده من الزلزال من زياره وزير
التعليم التركيه محمود اوزر الذي اعلن عن
اغلاق جميع المدارس في البلاد حتى الثالثه
عشر من الشهر الجاري
فخلا بعين الاعتبار المناخه والظروف
الحاليه في جميع انحاء تركيا ومن اجل
مواصله الاعمال في مناطق الزلزال بشكل
اكثر هدوءا ليس فقط في مناطق الزلزال بل
في جميع انحاء البلاد نعلن عن عطله في
جميع مدارس تركيا حتى الثالث عشر من
فبراير
احنا مرتاحين
يلا يا حجه يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
ونتابع واياكم في تضيف الى اعداد القتلى
في سوريا وصل عدد الى
1440 اضافه الى الرقم الذي لدينا عن تركيا
وهو
2316 قتيلا نتابع مع فراس رضوان اوغلو
الكاتب الصحفي من اسطنبول اذا في تعطيل
مدارس في زحمه اخف في اليوم كان في
اسطنبول على غير العاده ولكن ماذا عن بقيه
المؤسسات المواصلات القطارات المطارات
والقواعد الاجنبيه هل كل شيء من المنتظر
ان يعمل على عادته اما ان هناك اجراءات
استثنائيه في الايام على الاقل في الساعات
المقبله تحسبا للهزات
في اسطنبول يعني تقريبا كل الدوائر
الحكوميه كانت تسير في عملها الطبيعي دون
اي تغيير في انقره اظن نفس الشيء طبعا
الولايات العشره هذا امر خارج الموضوع لكن
ايضا يجب هناك كان خبر ايضا من البرلمان
التركي يتكلم عن فقدان الاتصال عن احد
النواب الاتراك عن مدينه اديمان يعقوب طاش
ولا نعلم اخر الاخبار هل تم العثور عليه
ام لا هذا من احد ربما المفقودين وفقا
البرلمان
التركي لكن حتى البرلمان سيعلق عمله في في
القادم الايام لم يحددها هل هو غدا لكن
بعد ذلك سيتخذ قرارات او ماذا
ستتضحها الامور القطار السريع ربما من
اسطنبول باتجاه انقره هو يعمل لم يتوقف
القطارات في ربما التي تصل بين المدن
باستثناء المدن الجنوبيه
يعني لم نسمع عن توقف القطارات بكل المدن
التي تعرضت الى الزلازل لكن
سمعنا عن توقف الطرقات البريه
هذا في وتحديدا في ملاطيا ومنطقه عثمانيه
فيها ضرر اكثر فيها الطرقات لكن طبعا ايضا
حتى الان لم يعلن عن افتتاح مطار انطاكيا
وايضا
عنتاب ولكن الاضنه وديار بكر واليزار
مطاراتهم مفتوحه ربما عنتاب تفتح مطارات
جانبيه ربما المطارات العسكريه
لقبول الطائرات المساعدات وصول الطائرات
المساعدات الى نقطه ممكن نقول في المنتصف
تصل شرقا وغربا في مرعى الشرقا وفي غربا
كلس وهاتاي يعني ممكن ان تكون ايضا مركزا
الوصول اسهل الى مناطق متعدده في هذا
السياق لكن حتى خطوط الجويه التركيه اعلنت
عن استمرار رحلاتها وبشكل غير متقطع وشكل
مستمر الى ديار بكر واليزاق وازرع في في
نفس الوقت يعني بمعنى ربما مدنيا ليس
عسكريا الجيش التركي مستمر في عملياته
الانقاذ والامور البحريه لان هناك ايضا
تدابير امنيه اخرى اتخذت يعني عدم استغلال
ربما هذه الفوضى التي حصلت بتسرب
اشخاص
مهربون ارهابيون او ما شابه ذلك استنفار
حقيقي امني في للدوله يعني مؤسسات الدوله
كلها تقريبا
لا يوجد مستثنى اي احد حتى الاجازات حتى
كل لا يوجد في هذا السياقك كما تفضل قبل
قليل الجامعات والمدارس كلها اوقفت حتى
الثالث عشر من هذا الشهر لكن لم يعلن الى
اي مدى ستوقف الرياضه شكرا جزيلا لك
الكاتب الصحفي في راس رضوان من اسطنبول
تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
عن تعزيه لاسر ضحايا الزلزال المدمر الذي
شهدته اراضي تركيا وسوريا مؤكدا على ان
الامم المتحده تدعو لمساعده المتضررين
ان انقل حزني من الزلازل المدمره التي
ضربت تركيا وسوريا كما اقدم احر التعازي
لاسر الضحايا والامم المتحده تدعو للعمل
لمساعده المتضررين من الكارثه فهم في امس
الحاجه الى المساعدات الانسانيه
اوضح وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن ان واشنطن تقيم خيارات الاستجابه
الشامله للزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا واكد بلنكن في بيان ان بلاده ستبذل
كل ما في وسعها لمساعده المتضررين خلال
الفتره المقبله مضيفا ان واشنطن على اتصال
وثيق مع انقره وشركائها في المجال
الانساني لتحديد ما تحتاجه المنطقه في
الايام القادمه
في تركيا جاريه بالفعل مؤكدا ان المنظمات
الانسانيه المدعومه من واشنطن في سوريا
تستجيب لاثار الزلزال في جميع انحاء
البلاد
هذا واكدت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولونا ان فرنسا سترسل 17 عنصرا من فرق
الانقاذ مع 65 عنصرا من فرق الاطفاء
لتركيا بالاضافه الى افراد من مركز
الازمات والدعم وذلك استجابه لطلب الدعم
الدولي الذي قدمته تركيا
يؤكد استعداد منظمه الامم المتحده لدعم
جهود الاستجابه الطارئه بعيدا وجهت فريقي
للتنسيق مع تركيا وتوفير المساعدات
اللازمه
بوتين مستعدون للمساعده في القضاء على
تدعيه الكارثه
فرنسا مستعده لتوفير مساعده عاجله للسكان
في تركيا وسوريا اسرائيل تعرض ارسال فرق
بحث وانقاذ وفرق طبيه الى تركيا وسوريا
المانيا تعهدت بتقديم مساعدات شامله
لضحايا الزلزال عبر كل الوسائل المتاحه
ايطاليا بدات بالفعل في تجهيز فرق الانقاذ
التي ستسافر الى تركيا
بكين تعلن استعدادها لتقديم مساعدات
انسانيه عاجله الى تركيا وسوريا
الى شبكه مراسلينا الان من واشنطن مراسل
العربيه بيرغانم من باريس مراسل العربيه
حسين قنيبر من بروكسل نور الدين الفريدي
مراسل العربيه ومن برلين مراسله العربيه
راغده بهنان اهلا بكم جميعا معنا وابدا
معك راغده من برلين اخر المعلومات عن
طبيعه المساعدات التي ستقدمها المانيا عن
طبيعه الاستجابه الالمانيه للزلزال
اهلا بك مساء الخير هي المانيا تنسق
بطبيعه الحال مع الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك
جزء من المساعدات يعني تجربه تنسيق مع
هيئه الاداره التي
ينسقها يتم تنسيقها من البروكسل ولكن ايضا
هناك صندوق حساسته صندوق طوارئ قدمت منه
مساعدات عاجله للصليب الاحمر الالماني
بقيمه يعني بقيمه اوليه بلغت 500 الف يورو
الصليب الاحمر الالماني ينفق بدوره مع
الهلال الاحمر التركي لتقديم المساعدات
المتوفره وزاره الداخليه الالمانيه اعلنت
عن انها ارسلت او سترسل يعني هذا كان
صباحا مساعدات عاجله تتمثل بمولدات
كهربائيه بطانيات وخيم وما يعني يمكن
استخدامه لمن يعني
دمرت منازلهم واصبحوا الان بحاجه الى هذه
المواد او يعني الامور الاوليه
هذه الاهتمام الرسمي والاعلامي والشعبي
كبير في المانيا بحكم وجود عدد هائل من
الاتراك هناك اليس كذلك هو السوريين طبعا
ولكن حتى الان يعني لم اقاله الخارجيه
بانه حتى الان ليس هناك اي معلومات بانه
هناك مواطنين المان في هذه المناطق ولكن
ايضا قالت بانه ليس كل من يذهب الى تركيا
يعني يسجل بانه موجود هناك لذلك ربما في
الايام المقبله او الساعات المقبله يتبين
عكس ذلك كنت اريد ان اذكر ايضا فقط بانه
المساعدات التي تذهب الى سوريا الحكومه
الالمانيه تقول الان بانها تناسقها عبر
المنظمات الانسانيه التي اصلا تنسق مع
المساعدات للمناطق السوريه هناك وحتى الان
ليس هناك تنسيق مع النظام السوري على
الاقل يعني ليس بطريقه رسميه او مباشره
نقطه مهمه شكرا راغده تبقينا معنا نحاول
ان نعرف الان
من بير غانم مراسل العربيه من واشنطن عن
طبيعه الاستجابه الام يبدو هناك يعني
تفاعل امريكي كبير جدا مع ما حصل ماذا
ننتظر منها
الامريكيون اعلنوا بشكل واضح انهم سوف
يرسلون فريقين اسعاف وانقاذ الى تركيا
خلال الساعات القليله المقبله هناك ايضا
مساعدات انسانيه سوف تقدمها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الى تركيا والى ايضا
السوريين كان هناك الكثير من الجدل حول
المساعدات الى سوريا وقد اصرت وزاره
الخارجيه اليوم بالقول على انها سوف توصل
المساعدات كما ذكرت زميلتنا من المانيا
قبل لحظات مثل الالمان ايضا ان هذه
المساعدات سوف تصل الى السوريين الضحايا
والمصابين عن طريق المنظمات الانسانيه
بالاضافه الى ذلك تحدث مسؤولون كبار في
الاداره الامريكيه الى نظرائهم في الحكومه
التركيه مستشار الامن القومي مباشره بعد
ان ضربت الهزه في تركيا اتصل بناظيره
التركي
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض ان الرئيس
بايدن كان يريد التحدث ايضا الى الرئيس
التركي ننتظر حتى الان تفاصيل عن هذه
المكالمه بين الرجلين وايضا وزير الدفاع
ووزير الخارجيه تحدثوا الى نظرائهم في
تركيا تبقى معنا لنتعرف الان على يعني
طبيعه المقاربه الاوروبيه للموضوع بشكل
عام لانه يعني اوروبا تتحرك ايضا على صعيد
جماعي وليس فقط على صعيد فردي مع نور
الدين فريد من بروكسيل
وماذا يعني تفعيل اليه الاستجابه
للازمات لتنسيق الدعم وفق ما اعلنه المجلس
الاوروبي الليله
يعني في هذه المرحله هناك ما لا يقل عن
تسعه عشر فريقا من فرق النجده والطب
العاجل تقدمها الدول الاوروبيه بالتنسيق
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي حيث يقوم جهاز
الحمايه المدنيه التابعه للاتحاد بتسلم
الطلبات من تركيا والتي تركزت في هذه
المرحله حتى هذه الساعه التي واللحظه التي
نتحدث فيها حول طلبي فرق الاغاثه والنجده
وفرق الطب العاجل في انتظار الطلبات
الاخرى التي قد تاتي في غضون الساعات
وخاصه في الايام المقبله طلائع هذه الفرق
الاوروبيه وصلت الى تركيا بعض الدول
الاعضاء
تتعاون مباشره مع تركيا بلجيكا على سبيل
المثال اعلنت قبل حين وضع طائره طائره نقل
عسكريه من طراز 400 وهي طائره اوروبيه
كبيره جدا تحت تصرف تركيا لنقل فرق
الاغاثه والمعدات الى غير ذلك ايضا هناك
مبادرات ستقوم بها ايطاليا
على صعيد ثنائي بينما يبدو بالتاليه ان
المساعدات تباعا ستصل بشكل منظم الى تركيا
في وضعا صعب جدا ولكن الوضع الاصعب هو
بالنسبه للشمال السوري سواء كان ما نراه
بالعين المجرده حسب ما ينقل الزملاء
وتقرير وكالات الانباء السوريون يجدون
انفسهم من دون مساعدات مباشره من دول
العالم هناك فقط المنظمات غير الحكوميه
ولكن الى اقاطعك التركيه
وبذلك يكون العدد 18 رافعه يتم تم ارسالها
الى المنطقه كما ايضا الطائرات مثل ما
قلنا في المؤتمرات السابقه تقوم باسعاف
المنكوبين
ونقل الجرحى للمشافه
بالنسبه
للاقامه
طبعا
هناك
طبعا بعض
[موسيقى]
اشخاص الذين تلقوا الدعم والمساعدات
حول
الخيم
والمعدات المطبخ
والبطانيات
[موسيقى]
نحن نقوم بتوجيه
المساعدات لهؤلاء الناس طبعا بالنسبه
لمراكز الاقامه ليس فقط الخيام بل ايضا
قلنا في المؤتمرات السابقه ان ايضا السكن
الطلاب والفنادق
والمضافات
جميعها مفتوحه
المنكوبين الان
وخمسين شخص يستفيدون من المضافات التابعه
لوزاره التعليم
وايضا
في الجامعات
والمضافات التابعه
عفوا اريد ان اجدد رقم وزاره التعليم
هناك تحديث
دائما يطرا على هذه الارقام
[موسيقى]
من الاشخاص المكوبين
الان
يقتلون مراكز الرياضه والملاعب
من طرف اخر بالنسبه للغذاء الهلال الاحمر
يلعب دورا
مهمه في هذه العمليه ايضا
ادارات المحليه
في المدن
يقومون بالتنسيق عمليه توزيع الغذاء
والطعام الساخن
على المنكوبين حتى الان الهلال الاحمر
وايضا وزاره التعليم
تقوم بتوزيع الغذاء
في
مرعشين والبستان وانطاكيا
يتم توزيع
الطعام على المنكوبين
[موسيقى]
الهلال الاحمر
بالفعاليات التوزيع
الطعم الساخن والشوربه على المنكوبين
وسيواصل دعمه لهذه الفئه من الناس
اريد ان ازودكم ببعض التفاصيل
طبعا الكهرباء وللقطاع يؤثر على عمليه
التدفئه على عمليه التواصل والاتصال
بعد المؤتمر الذي عقدناه سته
موزعات للكهرباء
الان خارجه عن
العمل
وباقي
الموزعات نقاط التوزيع
التواصل
فعالياتها
وهناك ايضا
الموزعات المتنقله التي يتم الان نقلها
الى هذه المنطقه في بحلول الاربعاء
والخميس والجمعه
سيتم الوصول الى هذه المنطقه
تم ايصال الكهرباء الى قهر
الريحانيه الان فقط منتصف او نصف
الريحانيه تصل يصلها الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
ايضا
ننتظر تاييد اداره الكهرباء بان ايصال
الخط الكهربائي ليس خطرا
لكي نفتح تيار الكهربائي
هذه المحافظه
في مدينه العثمانيه
ايضا سيتم
الفحص
الشبكه اذا كانت لن تؤثر على عمليه
الانقاذ
وسيتم فتح التيارات الكهربائي
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكتفي بهذا القدر من
المؤتمر الصحفي لاداره الكوارث التركيه
وطبعا الحديث كما هو في الاخبار العاجله
عن نائب الرئيس التركي نعمل على نشر
مولدات كهرباء في المناطق المنكوبه ننسق
عمليه توزيع الغذاء في المناطق المنكوبه
تحدث عن
2379 قتيلا اضافه الى
14,483 جريحا جراء الزلزال المؤتمر الصحفي
اذا كان لنائب الرئيس التركي حول تطورات
الزلزال والتداعياته واخر الارقام
والاحصائيات المؤسفه نعود الى شبكه
مراسلينا واتحول الان الى حسين قنيبر
مراسل العربيه من باريس
ليحدث معلوماتنا بشان طبيعه الاستجابه
الفرنسيه ايضا حسين
نعم في الواقع طاهر كما تحدث الزميل من
واشنطن وايضا الزميله راغده من برلين
المنظمات الانسانيه في فرنسا ايضا تلعب
دورا كبيرا وقبل ان ابدا بتفصيل المساعدات
الحكوميه الفرنسيه اشير الى بيان مهم صدر
عن تحالف من سته منظمات انسانيه فرنسيه من
بينها من بينها اطب
اطلق هذا التحالف دعوه للتضامن مع
المنكوبين ومساعده السكان في تركيا وفي
سوريا جاء في بيان التحالف ان مجموعات منه
متواجده على الارض في المناطق المنكوبه
ووفقا معلومات وزعها هذا التحالف من
المنظمات الانسانيه نقلا عن فرقه العامله
على الارض فقط شمل الدمار في سوريا مناطق
في حلب وابنه وايضا مناطق مجاوره
للمدينتين وعن تركيا وزع التحالف ارقاما
مهمه فقال
ان الدمار في تركيا شمله مدنا يسكنها 12
مليون شخص ومليون لاجئ سوري ايضا في لائحه
المدن المنكوبه التي وردت في البيان غازي
عنتاب اضنه اليمان ديار بكر اتاي كلس
وملكيا
ولمواجهه تداعيات ذلك جاء في بيان هذه
المنظمات الفرنسيه الانسانيه لمواجهه
التداعيات يجب القيام بتقديم مساعدات
عاجله وقد بدات هذه المنظمات بتقديمها لان
الاف المباني دمرت ومن ضمنها مستشفيات
دمرت هذه المباني على مساحه تبلغ 400 كيلو
متر على جانبي الحدود في جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا وسط ظروف مناخيه معقده جدا لناحيه
هطول الامطار بغزاره وتساقط الثلوج بكثافه
المنظمات الانسانيه الفرنسيه ارتفاع حصيله
الضحايا نظرا ليس فقط الى العدد الكبير من
الضحايا تحت الالقاب ولكن ايضا بسبب تشرد
الاف الاشخاص
فقارهم الى ماوى والى الغذاء والعنايه
الطبيه المنظمات الاعضاء في هذا التحالف
الفرنسي تقوم حاليا بتقييم الحاجات في
المناطق المنكوبه
من المرحله الاولى من المساعدات بالتنسيق
مع السلطات المحليه اخيرا على المستوى
الحكومي ستطلق فرنسا عمليه الحمايه
المدنيه وترسل في اطارها الى تركيا خلال
الساعات المقبله واحد 71 عنصرا من فرق
الانقاذ وخمسه وستين عنصرا من فرق الاطفاء
وافرادا من مركز الازمات والدعم التابع
لوزاره الخارجيه وسيسار ايضا الى ارسال
مفرزتين تابعتين لوزاره الداخليه متخصصتين
في البحث تحت الانقاض عن جثث او عن مصابين
ما زالوا احياء واخيرا عند التاريخ
الاشتراكيه ام ادالكو عب عن كامل دعمها
لفرق الانقاذ المنتشره في تركيا وسوريا
وقالت ان صندوق المساعدات العاجله التابع
لبلديه باريس سيستخدم لتامين مساعدات
عاجبه للمنكوبين طاهر شكرا على هذه
المعلومات تبقون معنا ان نذكر بانش دعت
اطراف الصراع في سوريا للسماح بمرور
المساعدات الانسانيه للمتضررين من الزلزال
وهذه الصور التي نشاهدها الان هي صور
مباشره لعمليات الانقاذ التي لا تزال
جاريه ومستمره في حلب السوريه
والكثير الكثير نتحدث عن الاف المباني
المدمره في سوريا وفي تركيا
والحديث ايضا عن عدد قتلى وجرحى سيرتفع
بشكل كبير جدا نظرا لبطاء عمليات الانقاذ
خاصه في الجانب السوري حتى تصل بقيه
المساعدات ايضا
ويعني عمليات الانقاذ ستبقى مست بطبيعه
الحال ولكن كلما يعني زاد الوقت كلما تقدم
الوقت كلما قل الامل للاسف هناك
انقاذ لسبعه الاف وثمانمائه واربعين شخصا
من تحت الانقاض بعد الزلزال حتى الان وفقا
لنائب الرئيس التركي الذي لا يزال يتحدث
في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي الذي نتابعه في جزء
من الصوره اضافه الى جزء اخر منها نشاهد
يعني من خلالها صور المزيد من تداعيات هذه
الماساه على السوريين وعلى الاتراك وهذه
الصوره تاتينا من حلب الكثير من الوجع
والالم والبكاء والكثير من الماسي
والمحاوله المساعده الانسانيه في هذا
الجانب يعني لا شيء يمكن ان يقوم به اي
احد في هذا الموضوع لمن فقدوا احبائهم
وخسروهم للابد
بالحظات قليله بثوان معدوده تعرضت فيها
هذه المناطق للزلزال للاسف الكثير من
الروايات المؤلمه والموجعه ولا شيء يضاهي
بعض الاهالي الذين يستطيعون ان يسمعوا
انين اقاربهم تحت الانقاض ولكن دون ان
يتمكنوا من الوصول اليهم نذكر بارتفاع
حصيله الزلزال في تركيا الى
2379 قتيلا وفقا لنائب الرئيس التركي
و14,483 جريحا جراء الزلزال اذا نواصل
معكم هذه التغطيه التي نتحدث فيها عن
زلزال خطير عن زلزال كبير جدا يعد وعدته
كل وكاله الانباء وكل المحللين والخبراء
في الزلازل انه حدث خطير حيث يعني
يعتبر من بين 20 زلزالا على مر التاريخ
بلغ متوسط
اكثر من سبع درجات عند هذا الصدع تحديدا
خط الصدع شرق الاناضول وهو خط زلزال نشط
بطبيعه الحال ويشهد عاده تشهد تلك المناطق
الكثير من الهزات ولكن ليس كهذه المره ليس
كهذا الزلزال التوقعات من قبل الخبراء
بوصول اعداد القتلى والجرحى الى عشرات
الالاف الى الالاف ان لم يكن عشرات الالاف
طبعا هناك الكثير الكثير من المساعدات
التي تعهدت بها الدول ولكن العديد من
عمليات العرقله الطبيعيه او ربما المفتعله
لان هناك تحذيرات ايضا خاصه في موضوع
الانقسام الحاصل في سوريا بين مناطق
موالات ومناطق معارضه لا تزال تسيطر عليها
هل سيحل هذا الموضوع تماما ام سيشكل عقبه
هذا تساؤل كبير اضافه الى حلول ساعه
الظلام الى برو الطقس القارس الان في تلك
المناطق يعني هناك عقبه حقيقيه في هذا
الموضوع ناهيك عن العوامل عوامل الانتشار
والانقاذ الاخرى بطبيعتها صعبه جدا وتحتاج
احيانا الى الكثير من المساعده الفنيه
والتقنيه وبالكلاب المدربه وبالاجهزه
اجهزه الاستشعار التي يعني هي غير متوفره
كثيرا في
الكثير من دول العالم او في عدد من دول
العالم نتابع مع مراسلينا هل هناك تفصيل
امريكي تحديدا رسمي بموضوع
الانقسام الحاصل في سوريا وامكانيه ايصال
المساعدات الى المناطق التي لا تزال تخضع
لمعارضه رغم او بالتزامن مع دعوات بعض
المنظمات الحقوقيه مثل منظمه
الى فتح كل
لايصال المساعدات هل من دعوه معينه
الامريكيون يريدون ان تبقى المعابر مفتوحه
وهذا يعني انهم يخططون لايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى سوريا عبر هذه المعابر من
تركيا هكذا هناك نقاش حامل الى حد ما بين
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه واحد
الصحفيين عند سؤاله حول هذا الموضوع واكد
ردا على هذه الاسئله ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سوف توصل المساعدات عن طريق
المنظمات الانسانيه رفض بشكل قاطع ان
تتحدث الحكومه الامريكيه الى النظام
السوري
ورفض طبعا لذلك وبرر بالقول ان هذا النظام
تسبب بمقتل الكثير من المواطنين وبالتالي
ليس من المعقول ان تعمل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مع هذا النظام لانقاذ شعبه
وبالتالي نحن نرى ان هناك موقفا امريكيا ن
ايضا ان نقول انه موقف اوروبي ايضا بعدم
التطبيع مع النظام السوري وان الطريقه
الوحيده لايصال المساعدات الى السوريين
سوف يكون عن طريق تركيا والمنظمات
الانسانيه
تبقى معنا
هل من يعني حل اوروبي
سيتم الركوب الى المنظمات الانسانيه ولكن
سيكون دون ذلك الكثير من العقبات ربما في
موضوع الانقسام الجغرافي المناطق السياسي
والامني اللي حاصل في في سوريا هل الاليه
التي اعلنها المجلس الاوروبي ربما ذكر
فيها او في ملحقاتها شيء من هذا القبيل
لحله
فعلا طاهر مثل ما تفضلت قبل حديث بيير عن
هذا الوضع المؤلم لان المشهد في الحقيقه
طبعا ومؤلم بين تركيا وعلى صعيد تركيا
وسوريا
وخاصه اذا نظرنا الى ان اكثر من اربعين
دوله اتصلت بالرئيس اردوغان وهي محقه في
ذلك وستقدم المساعدات وفرق الاغاثه
والنجده تصل تباعا الى تركيا بينما اتي
الفرق لا نراها على الاقل حسب التقارير
التلفزيونيه وما تنقله وكالات الانباء لا
نرى شيئا من هذه المساعدات قد وصل لنا
الرافعات لنرى الاجهزه المتقدمه الثقيله
التي يمكنها ان تساعد ان تساعد السوريين
في انقاذ ما يمكن من هو من هم تحت الانقاذ
سواء كان احياء او ربما جرحى وربما مصابين
يمكن انقاذهم فهنا يبدو ان الوضع يعني
مؤلم جدا
ويعني اسمح لي اننا نقول لك مثلا كلام
اللاجئين الذين اتصلوا وكان البعض منهم
يبكي لان اهله توفوا في حلب او هم يوجدون
في هذه اللحظات في مناطق عاريه من دون من
دون ماوى وان السوريين من حقهم ايضا ان
يشاهدوا ان العالم ربما لاسباب سياسيه
يتضامن مع تركيا وبسبب الوضع في سوريا
فسوريا يتركون لامرهم حتى تصلهم المساعدات
الانسانيه الان بشكل
دقيقيه اتصلت مع الاتحاد الاوروبي لطلب
هذه المساعده ولكن
مره اليوم ضحايا زلزال تركيا وسوريا الى
ثمانيه اضعاف
تلك المسجله الان اذا نحن نتحدث عن ثمانيه
اضعاف تلك المسجله وفقا للصحه العالميه